merci mon cher guillaume 1 il ya plein
de personnalités éminentes matin sur
cette table ont donc je vais faire court
je suis en charge des questions
internationales au parti et c'est sous
cet angle que je voudrais qu'on garde la
question migratoire
j'ai commencé par quelque chose qu'on
fait jamais c'est un peu de publicité
personnelle j'ai publié il ya 25 ans
seulement 2015 m'ont lié les sorties en
un livre qui tentait de voir ce qui
allait se passer après la guerre froide
qui s'appelait le nouveau monde de
l'ordre de yalta au désordre des nations
leaf qui a été l'époque couronné mais
j'essayais au moment le mur de berlin
tombait d'imaginer quelles seraient les
grandes forces du prochain monde et je
commençais et plusieurs forces
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive terrorisme et la première de ces
forces et la montée de l'asie première
de ces forces étaient la démographie
mais mme tribalat ne me démentira pas en
matière démographique on sait assez
longtemps à l avance et de façon assez
certaine quelles sont les grandes
tendances c'est par exemple
qu'aujourd'hui à 7 milliards d'hommes
qu'on va vers 9 10 milliards dans les
années 2000 5 ans on sait que la
population européenne restera stagnante
autour de 500 millions d'européens
mais vieillissant on sait qu'en face de
nous en afrique on va doubler la
population du continent africain autour
de deux milliards et demi d'hommes et on
savait et je l'avais écrit il ya 20 ans
25 ans que le nombre de personnes sont
des statistiques de l'onu pas inventé la
poudre ou c'est que la population en âge
de travailler de chercher un emploi de
l'autre côté de l'afrique entre 15 et 25
ans sera de l'ordre de 600 millions de
personnes c'est à dire plus que la
population européenne
si bien que si un sur dix de ces
africains désespéré par l'absence
d'emplois chez eux décident de franchir
méditerranée 14 km vous avez un
potentiel migratoire de 60 millions de
personnes et je citais abdou diouf qui
disait si vous essayez d'ouvrir les bras
vous n'arrêterez pas la flo les gens qui
viendront ça c'était il ya 25 ans
donc c'est dire que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ne me surprend pas du tout
quand j'étais ministre de l'europe en
athènes mes collègues du gouvernement
grec me demandait l'aide d'urgence de la
marine française pour contrôler les
milliers de côtes maritimes grecques à
l'époque
en 2009 la grèce interpellé cent
cinquante mille personnes dans destin
venue de turquie par voie de terre ou de
mères ayant laissé passer au tendon qui
rentrait dans la zone schengen
déjà 150 mille deux cent mille au moins
personne par la grèce à l'époque
berlusconi premier ministre italien à
coups de milliards d'euros ht l'a
achetée kadhafi complicité à une led de
kadhafi pour stopper contrôler les côtes
libyennes ne fasse qu'on se s que
s'arrête le flot de gens qui arrivaient
à lampedusa
c'était il ya déjà plusieurs années de
sa part de 7 8 ans mais ça fait très
longtemps que ça dure donc premiers
éléments ce qui nous arrive aujourd'hui
était hautement prévisible et est
parfaitement connue des gouvernements
depuis toujours
deuxième élément ce qui était moins
évident et qui était également dans mon
lit ya cinq ans mais avec une pas
l'interrogation c'était quid du monde
arabe
parce qu'il ya une chose qui était tout
à fait spectaculaire dans le monde arabe
c'était l'extraordinaire stabilité les
dirigeants pendant 40 ans on est même
les façades les benali et moubarak ces
mêmes régimes tout a sauté en 2011
taha nouveautés comme toujours à partir
d'une étincelle
le gouvernement tunisien et tomber ben
ali est parti s'entraîner à chute de
l'egypte a entraîné la guerre civile en
syrie s'entraînent une situation
aujourd'hui ou la totalité du monde
arabe est en flammes et ça va continuer
ça va continuer le drame c'est que au
proche orient
vous avez une réouverture entière des
frontières que nous français avec les
anglais nous avions tracé il y as tenez
vous bien 100 ans
sykes picot traité de versailles
on assiste est la deuxième des
colonisations de l'empiré ottoman au
moyen-orient rappelez-vous le liban la
syrie c'est nous qui les avons inventé
et nous qui les avons inventé ce qui
d'ailleurs disent qu'il faut aller faire
la guerre là-bas près bien de relire les
livres sur le mandat français en syrie
c'était un massacre on a rasé par deux
fois la ville de damas est donc cette
situation n'est pas près de se régler il
n'y a plus de syrie l'irak a implosé en
trois morceaux
donc il n'y a pas de perspective à
vision humaine à deux ans trois ans de
solutions évidentes à ce conflit
ce qui est sûr c'est mon analyse c'est
qu'on est rentré maintenant dans un état
de guerre permanent savait qu'on a
tendance nous à penser que le tome ps
est un moment
normal parce qu'on a vécu la guerre
froide et que s'est interrompue par des
moments de guerre sauf que aujourd'hui
on est dans un état de guerre permanent
ça veut dire que ceux qui vont essayer
de dire qu'il faut trier entre les
réfugiés de guerre jeudi pour mon propre
parti
les attentions réfugiés de guerre
réfugiés économiques
c'est pas évident moi qui ai passé
beaucoup de temps à m'occuper du sel
peux vous dire que le mali par exemple
où l'armée française est présente c'est
un pays qui est en guerre le niger est
un pays qui est attaqué sur deux
frontières
c'est même chose au tchad c'est la même
chose au nord cameroun
donc vous allez avoir du mal à faire la
distinction entre et donc premier donné
la révolution démographique c'est à dire
une implosion explosion démographique au
sud et un vieillissement au nord
deuxième donner une instabilité
permanente de guerre dans toute la
périphérie européenne troisième donnait
la légèreté la légèreté pour dire les
choses gentiment de la classe politique
européenne depuis 30 ans face à ces
sujets le je vais parler de la france
comment ne pas se souvenir que la faute
capitale a été commise en 1976 par la
droite au pouvoir
l'avènement du regroupement familial a
transformé une immigration de travail en
immigration de peuplement
on est passé de 300 mille personnes à
plusieurs millions aujourd'hui ça de
regroupement familial est donc l'une des
questions guillaume qu'il faudra
regarder ses coûts et du regroupement
familial qui est aujourd'hui dans les
textes européens
ça c'est 1976 qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
les chiffres en france hors crise du
moyen-orient
ces deux cent mille entrées légales
parent légal dont près de 100000 pour
leur cocon familial pour compter les
étudiants et autres 200000 plus 60 mille
demandeurs d'asile plus les clandestins
en moyenne la france voit arriver chaque
année 300 mille migrants sur son sol
dont deux cent mille sont légaux et on
naturalise depuis 40 ans à peu près cent
mille personnes par an voilà la
situation notre pays légèreté
monsieur renzi corps n y arrivent au
pouvoir en italie l'italie décide de ne
plus supporter seuls le ford le fardeau
de lampedusa transforme l'opération
frontex en marenostrum qu'est ce que
c'est que marenostrum c'est une
opération de sauvetage en mer par la
marine italienne
et on se met à sauver automatiquement
tous ceux qui sont sur les bateaux au
large des côtes libyennes
résultat le nombre des migrants et les
filières le savent
automatiquement maintenant que les gens
vont être ramassées par l'ama la marine
italienne
les chiffres explosent troisième
légèreté ce qui s'est passé depuis dix
jours la faute aux terribles de cet
enfant le 3 73 jours plus tard angela
merkel annonce que l'allemagne peut le
faire pour des raisons sans doute
personnel j'ai discuté beaucoup de ça
avec son entourage elle décide
brutalement de changer positions et
d'annoncer qu'elle accueillera tout le
monde est donc au lieu des 400 milles
attendus dans l'année on parle de 500
milles c'est le chiffre de frontex
800000 voir j'ai même vu le chiffre 11
certains dirigeants allemands de 1
million de personnes car tout d'un coup
naturellement la pression migratoire
venue du proche orient se réveille
moi je suis allé dans les camps en
turquie à gaz un tiers au liban jordanie
v 4 millions de personnes qui vivent
sous la tente ou dans les rues
d'istanbul à mendier ou par familles
entières
depuis deux ans trois ans si l'allemagne
annoncent que l'europe est ouverte
naturellement et humainement c'est tout
à fait compréhensible on passe en europe
et donc il ya eu le déferlement qu'on a
eues la semaine écoulée qui a absolument
saturé toutes les structures allemandes
et on en est aujourd'hui à la suspension
des accords de schengen par l'allemagne
et par ricochet par l'autriche
sans parler de l'attitude des pays de
visegrad de l'europe centrale
sans parler de l'opiniâtre traditionnel
des anglais et des tas doit donc
aujourd'hui schengen dublin
c'est terminé c'est suspendu et la
question qui se pose c'est naturellement
de savoir ce que nous ferons sont la
faire parce que bien entendu tous ceux
qui sont déboutés du statut de réfugié
en allemagne où est ce qu'ils vont aller
à votre avis ils vont aller dans les
endroits où il ya des prestations est
parmi les pays acp prestation on doit
être le plus généreux en europe avec
tout le régime que vous connaissez qu'on
a travaillé avec guillaume dans les lois
sur le droit d'asile
l'accès au logement les prestations
autour de 7 800 euros par famille la
gratuité des soins et c'est
automatiquement dès lors que vous
arrivez sur le sol de la france et c'est
là qu'il ya des différences évidemment
patente entre les différents états donc
on est dans une situation aujourd'hui
qui est gravissime sur un arrière fond
ou la zone euro est malade il n'y a pas
de défense européenne
pas de politique étrangère européenne où
les plans de relance ne marche pas et
nous avons un record de chômage en
europe
nous avons une crise migratoire majeur
et quant à notre pays
mais ça ce sera le sujet des discussions
suivante on sait touche tous les élus de
droite comme de gauche savent qu'il ya
plus de places d'accueil
il n'y a pas d'emploi il n'y a pas de
solution évident
et prétendre qu'on va intégrer 24000 en
plus c'est un chiffre d'ailleurs
complètement fumeux par rapport au
nombre on pense encore une fois c'est
entre cinq cent mille et un million que
la quote-part de la france à peu près de
24 mille sur deux ans ça c'est de
l'enfumage les chiffres n'auront pas
sont infiniment plus important et donc
on est dans une situation de crise
ce que je crois je termine là dessus ce
que l'urgence consiste à fermer tout de
suite la frontière entre la grèce et la
turquie
et ça ça demandera des moyens pas
seulement grecque met des moyens de
police est probablement plus de la part
des autres pays il faut que la frontière
soit scellé
sinon ce qui se passe au proche orient
les camps de réfugiés que vous avez en
turquie vous les aurez en
tout simplement ce sera une peine
immense vases communicants la deuxième
chose à faire c'est de revoir la copie
sur la protection des côtes libyennes
la troisième chose à faire il y en a
beaucoup c'est de suspendre l'accord de
schengen de renégocier tout de suite
un autre accord avec des conditions
beaucoup plus restrictive et les états
capables de défendre leurs frontières
sinon ça sert à rien schengen a été
conçu il ya 30 ans pour le confort et le
bien-être de européens entre eux
aujourd'hui on est dans un autre monde
et puis il ya toute une série de choses
juridiques sur lesquels parlons souvent
avec guillaume
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec le le regroupement
familial corps-morts harmoniser les
conditions d'accueil d'un pays à l'autre
nous sommes devant un problème
monumentale il est pas du tout sûre
aujourd'hui que l'europe s'en relève ça
va dépendre du sérieux des dirigeants et
pas de la légèreté que je vois où on
réagit à une photo ont réagi à une mode
médiatique bien sûr que l'instinct
normal d'une démocratie c'est la
générosité mais l'émotion la compassion
ne peuvent pas tenir lieu de politique
dans une situation aussi grave
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire